que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la crise du courant d'un virus s'aggrave
en amérique latine la situation est
effectivement assez cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 max hoarau ni
la gravité de la pandémie il a été élu
c'est par un dictateur il reste encore
populaire et donc évidemment sa façon de
se comporter par rapport au virus a de
l'impact auprès des brésiliens
aujourd'hui le gouvernement travaille
fortement pour s'approprier les
territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon et disparaît nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie pour le développement global
jeu car nous avons besoin aussi d'être
en paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
le président français est attendu ce
soir au liban pour la seconde fois
depuis la catastrophe au port de
beyrouth
seulement quelques heures avant sa venue
mustapha adib a été nommé premier
ministre du pays
il était jusqu'à présent basse adore les
libanais en allemagne désigné avec une
large majorité de députés
il va devoir relever le défi du
changement réclamé depuis des mois lors
de manifestations port du masque
distanciation physique ou encore baisse
du nombre d'élèves par classe à demain
c'est une rentrée scolaire inédite qui
attend 12 millions d'élèves avec des
inserts qui cliquent chez des
enseignants qui ont fait leur prérentrée
aujourd'hui est les mesures sanitaires
ont également été renforcées dans les
villes et les entreprises avec au centre
10 du dispositif le port du masque
nous y reviendrons avec renaud muselier
le président de la région sud provence
alpes côte d'azur et d'autres invités
politiques de ce soir
à la baisse serait elle enfin en vue au
soudan un accord historique a été signé
entre les rebelles et le gouvernement il
doit mettre fin à près de 17 ans de
guerre civile qui a mis le pays à genoux
cet accord prévoit entre autre l
intégration des combattants rebelles au
sein de l'armée régulière soudanaise un
an aura été nécessaires pour aboutir à
cette signature officielle de ce nom
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur rt
français et on débute avec l'arrivée
prévue dans la soirée des manuels macron
à beyrouth
à peine quelques heures après la
nomination du nouveau premier ministre
libanais mustapha adib un voyage
diplomatique de 24 heures pour tenter de
trouver des solutions à la crise
économique politique et sociale que
traverse le pays du cèdre
le 6 août dernier quelques jours après
les terribles explosions qui ont ravagé
la capitale libanaise
emmanuel macron exhortait la classe
politique du pays à proposer des
réformes d'urgence et à proposer un
nouveau pacte politique
à peine désigné le premier ministre
libanais moustapha al dib s'est engagé à
les appliquer claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales nous
renseigne sur la venue du président
français et de ses objectifs on écoute
cette promesse est faite confirmation de
sa venue a déjà eu un effet nous venons
d'en parler avec la nomination de ce
premier ministre réformateur
informateurs entre guillemets pour le
moment et il va consulter toutes les
forces politiques après s'être entretenu
avec le président de la république
monsieur michel ayoun et aussi avec bien
sûr le président du parlement qui est
président du parlement depuis 28 ans
monsieur nabih berry et donc il va
effectivement à nouveau leur dire c'est
à vous que le meut l'avenir du libre
appartient il faut que vous créer les
conditions d'une réforme de réformes
structurelles au liban sinon personne ne
fera crédit à ce pays et ne l'aidera à
se redresser et il s'entretiendra aussi
avec la population comme il l'a fait il
ya un peu plus de trois semaines
il y avait cette scène tout à fait
étonnant tous été pris à partie par une
jeune femme libanaise
il use et oui vous voulez vous parler
puis après vous passerai à autre chose
il a dit non je reviendrai le 1er
septembre et vous verrez que nous nous
allons nous allons progresser alors
peut-être la retrouvera t-il
en tout cas il retrouvera d'autres
personnages de la société civile qui lui
demanderont quelle est la prochaine
étape
et c'est donc mustapha addip qui est le
nouveau premier ministre
entre libanais âgé de 48 ans l'ancien
ambassadeur du liban en allemagne s'est
engagé à former rapidement son équipe
gouvernementale pour mettre en place des
réformes les détails tout de suite avec
walid bennani il est l'homme qui est
appelé à reconstruire un pays meurtri et
en colère
mustapha 10 48 ans ambassadeur du liban
en allemagne a été désigné premier
ministre ce lundi après avoir obtenu le
plus grand nombre de voix lors de
consultations parlementaires menés par
le chef de l'état michel aoun à la fosse
am l'opportunité devant notre pays et
les dalit de la tâche que j'ai accepté
beaucoup sur le fait que toutes les
forces politiques bien conscient de la
nécessité de former un gouvernement un
montant record est de commencer à mettre
en oeuvre des réformes avec comme point
de départ
d'accord avec le fonds monétaire
international
rennard des doigts d une annonce qui
survient alors que les parlementaires
ont négocié ces dernières semaines pour
désigner un nouveau premier ministre
après la démission du gouvernement
d'hassan diab le 10 août dernier
moins d'une semaine après la double
explosion qui a partiellement détruit la
capitale
le poste devait revenir à un musulman
sunnite en vertu du système
confessionnel qui organise le partage du
pouvoir entre les principales
communautés du pays
c'est ainsi que les partis sunnites ont
proposé le diplomate mustapha adib un
sou et validé par le secrétaire général
du hezbollah
l'organisation chiite très influente
dans la vie politique libanaise au nom
du bloc parlementaire loyauté à la
résistance nous avons notifié à son
excellence le président notre
approbation claire sur la nomination du
premier ministre désigné
mustapha a dit pour former un
gouvernement nous avons exprimé notre
entière disponibilité pour une
coopération positive et nous appelons
toutes les parties à coopérer dans
l'intérêt du liban
des déclarations qui corrobore le
discours tenu hier soir par le président
aoun qui s'est engagé sur la voie d'un
changement institutionnel profond alors
que jusqu'à la tragédie de beyrouth
ils semblaient insensibles aux
revendications des manifestants qui
contestent le système politique libanais
depuis plusieurs mois dans la foulée de
sa nomination
mustapha hadji s'est rendu dans un
quartier de beyrouth dévasté par la
double explosion
le nouveau premier ministre a demandé à
ses habitants de lui faire confiance et
de travailler je cite maintenant la main
l'avion du président français qui vient
tout juste d'atterrir à beyrouth on y
reviendra dans nos prochaines éditions
et on en vient à la rentrée scolaire en
france et elle est bien préparée selon
le ministre de l'éducation nationale en
visite dans un lycée en mayenne jean
michel blanquer se dit confiant à la
veille d'un retour en classe pour près
de 12 millions d'élèves et les
enseignants ont déjà retrouvé le chemin
de l'école
aujourd'hui pour la traditionnelle pré
rentrée une reprise placée sous le signe
du coc vite 19 avec la mise en place
d'un protocole sanitaire bien spécifique
est là mejjad l'exécutif tente de
rassurer les français inquiet d'une
vague épidémique selon le porte-parole
du gouvernement il n'y a pas lieu de
paniquer pour la reprise des cours tout
a été mis en place pour protéger les
enfants les enseignants pour la rentrée
scolaire
on a choisi le port du masque dès 11 ans
on verra si les adaptations sont
nécessaires
gabriella talent qui a profité de sa
prise de parole ce dimanche pour revenir
sur la non gratuité des masques à
l'école une décision vivement critiquée
il n'y a pas de raison que l'on
distribue des masques à des familles qui
ont les moyens de les payer il faut
cibler les publics que l'on accompagne
les foyers modestes
de son côté le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé succession de
réunions pour trouver des solutions pour
le bien-être des enseignants un prochain
grenelle axée sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail
le chantier de la deuxième partie du
quinquennat c'est la revalorisation du
métier sur le plan financier mais plus
généralement pour améliorer le bien-être
au travail
c'est pourquoi je lance un grenelle des
professeurs d'ici à octobre nous
discuterons de la hausse des
rémunérations pour 2020
1 grâce aux 400 millions d'euros
supplémentaires obtenus et à partir de
novembre
nous négocierons pour définir une loi de
programmation pluriannuelle
mais ça passe aussi par une
transformation profonde du système
éducatif et gestion des ressources
humaines place des enseignants dans la
société des maîtres heureux ce sont des
élèves heureux et une forme de sérénité
affichée au sein du gouvernement qui ne
rassure pas pour autant dans une tribune
publiée ce week-end sur le site du
parisien
un collectif de médecins appellent à
durcir les précautions au sein des
établissements scolaires
et en ce lundi de prérentrée pour près
de huit cent soixante dix mille
enseignants un vent de colère souffle
déjà professeurs étudiants et lycéens
doivent se retrouver en fin de journée
devant l'inspection d'académie de
seine-et-marne à melun
des manifestants qui veulent dénoncer la
gestion catastrophique selon eux de la
crise sanitaire
un appel au rassemblement lancé par une
intersyndicale et soutenus par des
parents d'élèves
et puis face à la hausse du nombre de
contaminations ces derniers jours la
ville de paris renforce son dispositif
de dépistage cinq sites dont deux
itinérant permettent aux parisiens de
passer gratuitement les tests qu'ovide à
ces espaces sont ouverts tous les jours
de 10h à 17h un dispositif qui doit
permettre de réaliser 1500 test par jour
à les parisiens se sont déplacés en
nombre pour se rassurer et publié parce
que le
la mairie de paris nous a demandé de
venir éventuellement cette perte est
restée ici
le monde a des doutes
dès qu'on sait pas si on est positif
ou négatif alors
tenir sa ferme
heureuse que jamais j'étais dans un
autre épicentre cabinet
donc c'est pour voir assuré sur
et j'espère etc mais j'espère vérifier
qu'en rentrant à paris
j'ai pas été contaminées en vacances
je suis
j'ai pas côtoyer connaissance de m
qui serait contaminée
et il est temps maintenant d'accueillir
notre invité politique rentrée scolaire
en pleine crise sanitaire la question du
port du masque la visite d' emmanuel
macron au liban entre autres on en parle
tout de suite avec renaud muselier est
président du conseil régional de
provence alpes côte d'azur membres les
républicains renaud muselier merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer un mot sur la visite d'
emmanuel macron au liban son avion vient
tout juste d'atterrir c'est la deuxième
visite en un mois avec une forte volonté
diplomatique de faire bouger les lignes
là bas au liban en pleine rentrée
gouvernementale en france avec des
dossiers sensibles à gérer alors est ce
qu'il est dans son rôle le président
français il est pleinement dans son rôle
on a eu autant les différents présidents
de la république qui au fil des ans
reçoit le président chirac le président
sarkozy même le président hollande b sur
le président mitterrand travailler la
main dans la main avec les chefs d'état
aujourd'hui au lendemain de ce désastre
cette catastrophe qui montre la
difficulté du fonctionnement du pays le
président mâcon est allé tout de suite
là bas sur zone
je ne sais pas en tournée cette fois ci
vers les dirigeants mais vers le peuple
en dix ans maintenant je reviendrai le
1er septembre et il faut modifier votre
dispositif politique qui est très
complexe au liban est aujourd'hui
incontestablement il arrive un nouveau
premier ministre et nouer avec un
consensus politique pour la gestion de
cette crise
c'est ce que ce sera suffisant c'est à
voir en tout cas il ya eu pour une fois
une modification de la gouvernance au
sein du gouvernement il est alors nommé
gelé alors qu'on voit en direct un ces
images le président michel aoun qui
attend donc le président français
emmanuel macron emmanuel macron qui
s'est exprimé vendredi la lie si nous
lâchons le liban ce sera la guerre
civile at il prévenu est ce que vous
rejoignez ses propos
au bien de la guerre civile le liban et
une son territoire a mis la france
francophone très important qui a réussi
à gérer un équilibre politique c'est
incroyable que sera le libanais sont
capables de faire mais aujourd'hui il
est au bord de l'implosion et donc aux
gars de la guerre civile ces sont les
iraniens à côté les palestiniens de
l'autre l'israélien du turc
les forces extérieures très puissante
avec bien sûr les grandes nations qui
sont deux épaules et et il se serait
dramatique pour la paix sur la
méditerranée pour un équilibre politique
que le liban implose
à cause de tout c'est un problème
politique qui perdure au fil du temps il
ya le volet religieux qu'elle voulait
constitutionnel dès le volet politique a
le volet financier et tout ça mis bout à
bout rend ce pays très très
difficilement ou même alors le président
mm macro 1 qui a insisté pour un
changement du gouvernement pour la mise
en place de réformes dans le liban au
nom de l'amitié franco-libanaise on ne
parle pas d'ingérence au nom de l'amitié
on parle de soutien vous savez on a
envoyé avec les régions de france des
deux millions d'euros on sait tous
mobilisés je présente des régions de
france
on a envoyé de marseille un bateau
affrété par un cma-cgm avec les très
grosses entreprises pour l'eau pour
l'aide alimentaire pour les deux
techniques pour les deux figures
les marins pompiers etc qui font sens
que l'on à ce que ce pays est en
déliquescence
avant ce désastre sur le port qui est le
fruit d'une mauvaise gouvernance soit
une absence de suivi
il y avait une crise financière majeure
crise financière majeure ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que quand vous êtes
dans une banque où vous ne pouvez sentir
que 150 euros par mois et vous avez
l'interdiction de sortir plus et ça
c'est très très compliqué en interne ce
pays où l'addition de toutes ces
complexités de toutes ces difficultés de
toutes ces pressions extérieures de tous
ces drames intérieurs avec un beyrouth
qui a été aux fabriques et on se rend
bien compte que la gouvernance était
nécessaire d'être changées est-ce que ça
suffira j'en sais rien mais en tout cas
je pense que là la france fait son rôle
d'ami voilà on voit ces images en direct
par le président emmanuel macron qui va
sortir d'ici peu de son avion une
dernière question à propos du liban
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
visite de 24 heures diplomatique
j'attends que le président de la
république soutenue par les
nations-unies puisse faire en sorte que
le libor ne soit plus le lieu de toutes
les toutes les turpitudes et est-ce
qu'il va y arriver il faut le souhaiter
pour notre pm tous
renaud muselier je vous propose
d'attendre revenir à l'actualité
ici en france et donc la retrait la
rentrée demain dans une atmosphère de
crise sanitaire il y à des enseignants
qui sont inquiets il ya aussi des
médecins
vous êtes médecin des médecins qui ont
signé ce week end à une tribune dans le
parisien dénonçant un protocole
sanitaire trop léger mise en place par
l'éducation nationale
est ce que cette veille de rentrée en
tant que président de région vous êtes
inquiet l'entente que médecin je
n'aurais pas signé cette déclaration je
pense que on à la nécessité de s'adapter
à ce qu vide et faire en sorte que l'on
retrouve la vie différente mais avec nos
libertés mais liberté qui s'adapte à ce
problème de santé publique majeur
pourquoi cela prend le sentiment je
jouais bien l'exemple de la région
commencent à choisir tout particulier à
marseille on a aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de l'incidence de la transmission vous
savez que ça nous c'est très important
on a 100 77 pour cent mille habitants
alors que la france est à soixante dix à
peu près mais on a eu depuis moins de
joie un seul mort de 85 ans dans
l'animation et une seule personne
hospitalisée en réanimation à youtube et
ventilés c'était en fait on est face à
une progression réelle mais en même
temps une absence totale de mort et donc
il faut raison garder et ne pas en
permanence c'est tout
alarmiste étrangement alors il faut
raison garder est-ce qu'on imposant le
masque par tous y compris pour les
élèves dans les collèges à partir de 11
ans est ce que c'est une bonne chose
selon vous je suis plus réservé sur le
traitement des crises sanitaires j'avais
mes amis toutes ces réserves d'ailleurs
dans le pic de février mars où on est
mon côté médecins urgentistes fait en
sorte que spontanément j'ai pas envie de
créer de polémique dans des décisions
politiques qui essaye de répondre à une
crise sanitaire qui est incontrôlée on
se retrouve aujourd'hui avec iphone ce
nom masqué tout le monde vieillit avec
notre gouvernement travaille surtout de
permettre de masquer nom de groupe cela
justement comment vous comprenez qu'est
ce qui s'est passé finalement en
quelques mois pour passer du le masque
n'est pas nécessaire à aujourd'hui il
est indispensable partout même dans la
rue je pense que scientifiquement
parlant un médicalement parlant de la
culture que l'on a maintenant sur le
retour comme ce soit en chine que ce
soit aux états unis que ce soit sur les
pays qui ont donné dès souvent non on se
retrouve dans une situation où de toute
façon se laver les mains est essentiel
est resté à distance aussi et le masque
en vase clos et et est essentielle après
il était jusqu au boutistes qui pensent
qu'il faut que seulement les mettre dans
l'espace public
moi j'entends tout cas pas argent
pendant sa cote azur
on a acheté 14 millions de masques comme
personne en avait on les a fait venir on
a équipé nos personnels de santé nos
entreprises nous lycéens nous abonner et
on a aujourd'hui pour chacun de nos
lycéens c'est là près de 200000 qui sont
qui vont rentrer des masques lavables 35
fois aide toi le ciel t'aidera fixe ou
taurine doctrine c'est ce que nous avons
fait ici en se disant que la vie doit
continuer quoi qu'il arrive alors cette
crise du conte vidal a aussi des
répercussions économiques
que le pib a chuté de près de 14% au
deuxième trimestre vous êtes inquiet
pour les prochains mois je trouve que
dans tant que maître des jugements mais
c'est tout ça c'est derrière sur la clé
sanitaires autant je trouve que ce qui a
été fait par le gouvernement sous
l'autorité de monsieur bruno le maire
l'ancien gouvernement sur la crise
économique a été plutôt bien fait tout
bien fait parce que il ya eu de l'aide
sur les filières et de lettres présente
reprise à une vision sur la
réindustrialisation nous-mêmes ans nous
avons eu autant que le président de
région la capacité d'intervenir dans
toutes nos régions puisque c'est dans
domaine de compétence avec l'économie on
a apporté des fonds qu'au vu de
résistance ont amené trésorerie on a
essayé de sauver l'entreprise en tout
cas est de sauver les emplois
pour autant bien entendu ceux qui
étaient en très grande difficulté on ne
pourra pas les sauver je crains dans le
cadre d'une semi confinement en fait
imposée par le gouvernement une nouvelle
crise potentiel économique et le
j'attends avec impatience le contrat de
plan de relance du premier ministre
monsieur castex qui est incontestable en
sera différent et qui j'espère tiendra
compte des difficultés des entreprises
dont notamment la trésorerie est pas
réellement à ça c'est ce que m'arrive
pas bien mesuré c'est que si cette crise
économique n'est pas bien traité
on en rate immédiatement une
répercussion avec une crise sociale est
là alors là c'est la denture dans un
pays qui souffre et qui est en très
grande difficulté sociale on parle
également beaucoup des violences ces
derniers jours à regard de la violence
dans notre société vous le comprenez
comment je vais jamais à venir jamais
admis la violence je suis dans la
culture du respect respect de moyenne
avec eux ce que j'ai à dire la façon de
présenter le respect la république le
respect des règles des lois et le
respect de l'autorité et on est dans un
pays qui a perdu beaucoup en respect de
l'autorité
donc tout ce qui représente une autorité
que ce soit un médecin un professeur un
policier un gendarme et un pompier
représente quelque part une tribu
adverse et donc je fais là dessus très
attentif
au couple police justice parce que je
pense que la justice doit être rendue de
façon immédiate sans concession pour
tous ceux qui font des atteintes à la
liberté et d atteinte à la république
des atteintes à anoblir façon tout à
fait stupide et imbécile et ceci sans
sens ans en position d'arrière et donc
la république elle doit on sait une
indivisible
avec la justice et la justice se doit de
passer vite et bien pour conclure renaud
muselier une question un peu plus
politique
ce week-end c'était la rentrée des
républicains à la baule les potentiels
candidats pour représenter votre parti à
la prochaine présidentielle vont
progressivement se déclarer une annonce
très attendue celle de françois baroin
notamment est ce qu'il ya une figure qui
se détache aujourd'hui selon vous pour
incarner les valeurs des républicains et
en même temps pour offrir une véritable
alternative à emmanuel macron en tout
cas notre formation politique existe la
rentrée officielle finalement piloté par
l air aura lieu ce week-end et j'y serai
bien entendu sa cote est de paris koffi
le mans et mesure de précaution
indispensable
nous avons notre 50 ans de genre et de
candidats potentiels se prouve que la
vivacité il ya de la vie il ya des
différences pour moi je suis pas dans la
guerre des personnes je suis pas non
plus dans le savoir exactement dans le
cadre du programme qui et pour qui
kiffent pourquoi on est dans le sens
sibilité politique de la droite et du
centre qui se doit d'être organisés et
si on est très bien organisée sur le
plan territorial
on a un manque d'incarnation au niveau
national christian jacob et en le
ciblant de tout ça et de faire un grand
talent je dirais que plutôt que de
savoir qui est capable d'y aller car est
pourquoi je préférerais qu'on décale
d'abord un je pense qu'il faut pas de
primaire moi je pense que c'est pas la
peine air france rappelle pourquoi pas
de primaires parce que la fois on a fait
une primaire ouverte avait été
remarquable assez exceptionnel et
d'autres candidats s'est écrasé en plein
vol en janvier donc c'est pas la bonne
formule
lorsqu'il faut attendre le mois de mars
ils attendent mois de mars pour voir
comment ça se passe au niveau national
ne pas parasiter tous en même temps
dans le cadre de de 7,7 relance ou
choqué sur la crise économique et
sanitaire e puis de calme et sociale
plutôt et donc attendant de passer les
élections départementales et les
régionales pour voir s'il ya un candidat
chez nous qui se dégage et puis après on
trouvera le moyen de 2 le départager
merci beaucoup rené muselier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur
toujours en france où la menace
terroriste demeure extrêmement élevé
selon le ministre de l'intérieur en
déplacement au siège de la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure elle
faisait râle darmana a précisé je cite
que le risque terroriste d'origine
sunnite demeurait la principale menace à
laquelle est confrontée notre pays
à ce jour plus de 8000 personnes sont
fichées pour radicalisation à caractère
terroriste écoutez à ce sujet gérald
darmanin des dispositifs particuliers
ont été mis en oeuvre pour renforcer la
prise en compte de la menace carcérale
dans sa triple composantes
l'environnement carcéral la menace
projeté depuis des lieux de détention
la menace diffuse et à long terme
nourrie par le prosélytisme religieux
émanant d'individus à ce jour 500 cinq
détenus terroristes islamistes en lien
avec la mouvance islamiste dix sont
actuellement recensés auxquels s'ajoute
malheureusement cette sont des détenus
de droit commun susceptible de
radicalisation le défi sécuritaire
majeur pour les services de
renseignement en 2020 se traduit
notamment par les prévisions de
libération qui sont évalués à 45 détenus
condamnés pour des faits d'association
de malfaiteurs terroristes et elles
feront l'objet d'un suivi
particulièrement attentif je veux le
dire à nos compatriotes se chiffrent
connaîtra une nouvelle hausse en 2021
avec la sortie prévisionnel de 63
terroristes islamistes condamnés au
cours d'une réunion spécifique tenue en
début d'après midi j'aurai confirmé que
le suivi des sortants de prison devait
constituer pour le présent de la
république et le gouvernement
l'une des priorités du système la
priorité confiée aux services de l'état
c'est l'accord qui va peut-être changer
l'avenir du pays après des années de
conflit
le soudan signent un traité de paix le
gouvernement et les groupes rebelles à
la même table on signait une image forte
après plusieurs tentatives de paix dans
le passé le soudan reprend son souffle
un événement historique pour le pays
les explications de monaco dès lors il
aura fallu un an de négociations le
soudan s'apprête à tourner le dos à 17
ans de conflit un traité de paix
historique vient d'être signé par le
gouvernement soudanais et les cinq
principaux groupes rebelles du pays
une étape fondamentale pour le soudan
déchirée depuis plusieurs décennies déjà
le pays a connu plusieurs échecs
d'accord le premier en 2006 au nigeria
et le second au qatar en 2010 le soudan
avait donc besoin de ce nouveau souffle
le rêve est devenu réalité après des
efforts considérables qui ont permis
d'arriver à un accord de paix entre le
gouvernement et le front révolutionnaire
soudanais pour saisir l'importance de
cet accord il faut comprendre le
contexte soudan une des régions les plus
touchées par le conflit et le darfour à
l'ouest du pays en 2003 le conflit
éclate entre le régime à majorité arabe
du président déchu rahmane el béchir et
des insurgés issus de minorités
ethniques qui estime être marginalisés
les tensions sont vives et la guerre
fait plus de 300000 morts et 2,5
millions de déplacés selon l'onu
en 2011 elle la rébellion s'étant à la
région du kordofan sud et du nil bleu
les violences n'ont pas commencé en 1989
avec l'arrivée d'omar el-béchir la
discrimination l'absence de partage du
pouvoir de partage de ressources
tout cela a commencé en 1956 juste après
l'indépendance
et après tout ce temps que nous ayons
enfin réussi à trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes est une véritable victoire
les gens sont contents pas seulement les
hommes politiques ou les groupes armés
mais également la société civile tous
ceux qui vivent dans des camps au
darfour et qu'ils ont une histoire
tragique
il faut dire que le soudan était sur la
bonne voie puisque cette dernière année
les violences avaient diminué
omar el béchir a été renversé par
l'armée sous la pression de la rue en
2019 et cet accord sont encore plus fort
car le procès de roms à lille béchir
aura justement lieu le 1er septembre
mais que contient ce traité
bien les rebelles et le gouvernement ont
paraphé vie protocole sur les thèmes
suivants entre autres le partage du
pouvoir la sécurité la justice et au
retour des réfugiés
autre point important de cet accord il
stipule que les mouvements armés seront
démantelés et que leurs combattants
devront rejoindre l'armée régulière qui
sera réorganisé pour représenter toutes
les composantes du peuple soudanais
mais il reste encore du chemin à
parcourir deux factions rebelles ont
refusé de prendre part à l'accord mais
le gouvernement espère tout de même
pouvoir les convaincre de déposer les
armes
et avant de clore c'est ce journal ces
images en direct depuis le port de
beyrouth le président emmanuel macron
vient d'arriver on le voit ici aux côtés
du président michel aoun le président
français pour sa deuxième visite au
liban depuis l'explosion tragique du 4
août pour tenter de résoudre une crise
politique profonde et pour célébrer le
premier centenaire de la proclamation du
grand liban on y reviendra dans un peu
plus de trente minutes dans notre rare
aux chaînes édition elle c'est donc la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
restez avec nous sur rt france a
totalement
et
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
[Musique]